Bonjour.
Aujourd’hui
est un jour
très important pour moi.
Dans la vie
Y’a des projets qui te prennent
plus ou moins de temps.
Par exemple
Une vidéo ça peut
prendre plusieurs semaines
Un court-métrage
ça va vous prendre des mois.
Là on a changé de catégorie.
Je viens vous parler du projet
Qui nous a demandé le plus de temps
le plus d’énergie,
et dont je suis extrêmement fier.
Aujourd’hui
sort notre jeu mobile gratuit
et j’ai pleins de choses
à vous dire dessus.
Pour commencer
ça peut se traduire par  gagne plus de vues ”
mais c’est plus stylé Make More Views.
Le but du jeu c’est de faire pleins de vidéos
d’avoir le meilleur décor
et d’avoir, le plus d’abonnés.
Un peu comme dans la vraie vie en faite.
Je vous vois arriver,
c’est quel type de jeu ?
C’est un clicker, ou un idle game
donc en gros tu dois cliquer à fond
pour produire des vidéos
mais la production
se fait aussi toute seule
donc tu as le choix,
en gros
tu lances une production de vidéo
soit tu cliques pour accélérer la production
ou alors tu fermes le jeu,
et tu auras une petite notif
quand la vidéo sera produite.
En gros tu peux jouer
comme un fou toute la journée.
Ou alors juste un peu de temps en temps.
ça dépend des gens,
c’est le principe d’un clicker.
Alors on le sait, quand je dis on
je parle du studio La Gamerie
avec qui on a déjà fait
le Nope Quiz y’a quelque temps
et y’a que 3 personnes dans le studio,
je reviendrais dessus plus tard
c’est pas le premier jeu
où tu crées une sorte de youtuber.
ça on sait, y’a eu
Tuber Simulator de PewDiePie
y’a eu Youtubeurs life, ce genre de chose
mais nous on a essayé d’apporter
quelque chose de différent
et de mieux sur certains aspects
Notamment, la customisation.
On a fait en sorte,
que n’importe qui
peut créer le personnage qu’il veut
avec un nombre d’éléments
personnalisable sur le personnage.
Un petit exemple,
on va jouer à un petit jeu
J’ai créé plusieurs personnages
qui s’affichent à l’écran
et vous allez essayer de me dire
dans les commentaires, qui j’ai essayé  de reproduire
et ça par exemple, c’est moi.
Bon c’est moi version Make More Views.
Et la customisation,
c’est aussi le studio.
Pour nous c’était important
d’avoir un studio
qui reflète un peu
les goûts de chacun
qui peut être plus lifestyle,
qui peut être plus gaming
autre chose différente dans MMV
c’est l’histoire.
Même si c’est un clicker,
on a essayé de créer
une histoire avec un début,
un milieu, des twists
plus vous progressez dans le jeu
plus vous allez rencontrer des personnages
d’autres créateurs de vidéos
des ennemies, des alliés,
un mentor
C’est un truc qui est assez
important pour nous dans le studio
c’est-à-dire de pas faire
juste un jeu bête où tu cliques
c’est essayer de créer
des personnages attachants
et aussi de pouvoir développer
des vraies petites histoires
même si c’est un clicker,
c’est un pari un peu risqué
mais nous, on est très fier de ça.
et encore une chose qu’on a essayé
de rendre un petit peu différent dans MMV
c’est le gameplay,
c’est-à-dire qu’il suffit pas de cliquer bêtement
pour produire des vidéos
y’a des séquences de
gameplay qui vont se lancer
beaucoup de mini-jeux,
que vous débloquerez au fur et à mesure
en gros on veut que
le joueur ne s’ennui jamais.
Y’a toujours un petit truc qui arrive
un événement à accepter, à refuser
des mini-jeux à taper,
à slider, à ce que vous voulez
On espère vraiment que
le gameplay va vous plaire.
Quand vous commencez
le jeu, vous aurez le choix
entre 3 thématiques de chaîne.
entre le gaming,
le lifestyle, la science
en fonction de vos choix,
vous aurez une histoire différente
des miniatures différentes,
des titres de vidéos différentes
des personnages différents.
Et on travaille déjà
sur des prochaines chaînes
à ajouter dans les futures mise à jour.
On a essayé de créer une dimension RPG
Donc en gros, plus vous produisez des vidéos
plus vous gagnez de l’expérience,
vous gagnez des niveaux
et vous améliorer des compétences.
et y’a aussi plein d’équipement,
que vous pouvez améliorer
par exemple, la caméra,
l’ordinateur, votre fond vert
au début on commence
avec des éléments tout claqué
c’est normal.
Et plus t’avances dans le jeu
plus ton équipement mon pote,
c’est de la top qualité.
Et faire des vidéos tout seul,
c’est pas drôle et c’est pas facile
Donc tu as des employés
Dans MMV tu peux
avoir plusieurs employés
tu peux avoir un technicien,
un scénariste, un community manager
ils vont t’aider à produire
plus rapidement des vidéos
ou gagner plus d’argent
par contre un truc très important
c’est qu’il faut les payer
et d’ailleurs si tu les payes
pas du tout, ils se mettent en grève.
Et bien évidemment,
il faut gagner des abonnés
c’est important ça
donc une des manières de gagner des abonnés
c’est de répondre à des commentaires
qui sont en fait des sortes de missions,
qui te demandent de changer quelque chose
dans ton décor, ou sur toi
ou d’atteindre un objectif,
un peu comme dans la vraie vie
si t’écoutes tes abonnés,
tu gagnes plus d’abonnés.
et toi en tant que jouer,
tu veux avoir le plus d’abonnés possible
pour être le plus haut dans le classement
parce que oui y’a
un classement en ligne
d’ailleurs tu peux visiter
les apparts de tous les joueurs
Prendre un petit peu
d’inspiration par exemple.
Maintenant faut que
je vous parle du modèle économique
puisque c’est un free to play
c’est-à-dire que le jeu est gratuit
mais si vous voulez avoir
un petit plus de gain
par exemple vous pouvez
regarder une publicité
mais c’est pas obligé,
et si vous voulez gagner du temps
sur la livraison d’un équipement,
ou la production d’une vidéo
vous pouvez dépenser des gemmes
que vous pouvez acheter dans le jeu
mais c’est pas obligé
on a essayé d’offrir la meilleure
expérience de jeu possible
pour n’importe quel type de joueur.
Que vous voulez gagner un peu de sous
et gagner du temps ou non
ou si ça vous dérange ou non
de regarder une publicité
On a fait en sorte que le jeu
soit quand même plaisant
et la progression soit
cool pour tout le monde.
c’est important pour nous d’offrir
une très belle expérience,
pour n’importe quel type de joueur
Le jeu est dispo
dès maintenant sur iOS et Android
vous pouvez les télécharger,
jouer sur votre smartphone
votre tablette,
ce que vous voulez
et actuellement
il y a un événement
pour débloquer des objets que
vous pouvez avoir que au début du jeu
c’est un petit cadeau
pour fêter le lancement du jeu
Profitez -en c’est maintenant,
puisque le mois prochain
On ne pourra plus gagner
ces objets, c’est terminé
On va essayer de créer
plusieurs évènnements comme ça
un peu tout au long
de l’année, l'année prochaine
On vous a réservé
des petites surprises
J’espère que ça va vous plaire.
Faut savoir que dans le studio,
on est une toute petite équipe
On est que 4 personnes en moyenne
alors que sortir un free to play
normalement c’est des
dizaines de personnes
On peut officiellement dire
qu’on avait pas très bien mesuré
la charge de travail qui nous attendez
et ça explique pourquoi,
j’avais annoncé ce jeu
il y a 1 an et demi
et on a pris plus d’1 an de retard.
On s’excuse, et pour vous prouver
que l’équipe est très petite
chacun dans le studio
était multicasquette
par exemple Jérémie qui est le dev,
a fait aussi les musiques du jeu
Etienne le directeur artistique,
qui a fait tous les éléments graphiques
a fait aussi l’histoire
et le game play
et ensuite tous ensemble,
on a créé le game design
avec des idées d’objet, de décor, etc
ça nous a pris un temps de fou
On est tellement content
de sortir enfin le jeu
ça fait si longtemps
qu’on est dessus.
Et ce n’est pas terminé puisqu’il
y a pleins de mises à jours qui sont prévues
avec des nouvelles
thématiques de chaîne.
du contenu, des objets,
des évènnements
et aussi des idées pour d’autres
fonctionnalités qu’on va intégrer
c’est un jeu qui va
continuer encore d’évoluer.
Voilà je vous l’ai dit,
c’est un jour très important aujourd’hui
puisque ce projet de
dingue qui nous a occupé
pendant longtemps et qui va
encore nous occuper longtemps
est enfin sorti
N'hésitez pas à nous donner
votre avis sur l’AppStore
sur Google Play,
en mettant des étoiles
c’est important pour nous
J’espère que vous allez vous amusez
Qu’on va vous surprendre encore avec la suite
A vous de télécharger le jeu !